Liz Chaplin says she hasn't slept for 11
years a mother of two
she's also a full-time carer for one of
them eleven-year-old Ava she contracted
an infection when I was pregnant she's
fully dependent on us for all I care
needs so washing dressing changing she's
nonverbal so is unable to communicate
her needs which can make it very
difficult Liz is one of thousands of
parent carers who say they need more
help a survey by the disabled children's
partnerships the coalition of charities
found that only 4% of parent carers say
they get the right support to safely
care for their disabled children there's
no guidebook there's no handbook into
how you raise a child with complex needs
you learn on the job and you're
basically end up doing a job that you're
not adequately trained to do the courage
it takes to build up to ask for help it
is the what a thing any mum ever has to
do to put their hand up and say I'm
coping
the government says it has made four
hundred and ten million pounds of
vailable to local authorities this year
specifically for adult and children's
social care with 46 point four billion
pounds available this year for local
services including children's services
disabled children are legally entitled
to things like home support and access
to equipment but local authority
cutbacks means some of these services
official services are sometimes missed
out this short film released on social
media today is calling on the government
to give back the millions the DCP says
is owed to families of disabled children
it comes alongside a letter to the
Chancellor from one mum who urges the
government to fund vital services for
families to care safely for their
disabled child calling on other parents
to add their names the letter echoes
what Liz says is a need to act early
before parent carers reach breaking
point
themselves Sadia Chaudhary Sky News